yes we had always hoped that he would be
here for the opening of course before he
was arrested we always assumed he would
be here
in October Washington's hirshhorn museum
opened I way way according to what the
first major retrospective of works by
the Chinese artist in North America I
believe this show is extremely important
fry way way Harry Brauer is the chief
curator at the Smithsonian's Hirshhorn
Museum we provided him with a platform
in a way for him to speak out with his
art in a way that he hasn't been able to
do before in the United States the show
has received glowing reviews from art
critics and visitors alike the artist
himself might share that view if he ever
gets the chance to see it unfortunately
as we were in the middle of working with
AI weiwei on the exhibition he of course
was arrested in China and incarcerated
for illegal was 81 days ever since we
was released and they they put these
conditions on him where they said you
know in a year we'll give you back your
passport I've been thinking you know
he's got to get his passport back Alison
Clayman is the director of AI weiwei
never sorry the critically acclaimed
documentary about the artist and his
history of confrontations with the
Chinese government we was born in 1957
to I Ching who is one of his country's
most famous modern poet he had been part
of this wave of intellectuals and
artists who had freely expressed
themselves under the hundred Flowers
movement and then now kind of cracked
down on all of those voices and so way
we was born at the moment when I Ching
was sent into domestic exile in far
western China where he then spent the
next 18 years essentially labeled an
enemy of the people a class enemy so I
think way also at a very early age was
had a completely clear ID picture of
what a state power can do to an
individual I like to think of it as way
sort of left from the art pages on to
the new section around the time of the
Olympics he helped hertzog and emraan
the Swiss architects design the bird's
nest stadium which ended up winning the
design context when he was interviewed
about his work which he was very proud
of the stadium itself he
very publicly said you know I think
these games are a sham there a fake
smile for the rest of the world and it's
not about China joining international
community and international values and
so I'm not interested in the games at
all and i'm not even going to go that
was around 2007-2008 was then the source
of the next big clash and that was the
citron earthquake there seemed to be a
disproportionate number of municipal
buildings and schools that were
collapsing that were built in the last
couple decades and and it just started
to look a little bit unusual because
sometimes those buildings would be
completely collapsed and the ones next
to them were still standing and so we
decided to do a project that would
spotlight and honor the deaths of the
schoolchildren in the sichuan earthquake
but when he put a call on line to his
fans on his blog to help collect the
names of the students who died because
the government said it was a state
secret when he shared all that online he
ended up with his blog being shut down
with surveillance cameras being
installed all around his house by the
authorities and when he went to kind of
stand up for another activist he ended
up getting severely beaten which forced
him into go to emergency surgery the
government demolished a newly built
studio that he was actually invited to
build by the local mayor that was
January of 2011 and it was just a couple
months later that way way was taken into
secret detention for 81 days and his
studio was completely rated after his
release I weiwei returned to his
activism speaking to the wider world
through the use of a tool authoritarian
governments are finding increasingly
difficult to control the Internet I
think for a way with the one source of
the optimism does come from new
technology and the internet and the idea
that people can express themselves be
connected see things outside their own
context both within China and globally I
think that Internet is extremely
important to AI weiwei I actually think
he's one of the first artists who's
actually you
in a kind of proactive way whether it's
self installing surveillance cameras
inside his bedroom as a gift to security
officials appearing in handcuffs during
a widely viewed Gangnam style parody
where his enthusiastic embrace of
Twitter as a medium of expression
highway ways reputation on the world
stage has arguably grown larger despite
the Chinese government's attempts to
rein him in there is a blurring of his
internet activity and his art so that
his internet activity becomes his art in
many ways it becomes a performance piece
in some ways there's no direct dividing
line between the sculptures that are in
this gallery and what happens when he
actually sends things out to the
thousands of people that are following
him the exhibit will remain in
Washington until the end of February at
which point the show is scheduled to
move to Indianapolis Toronto Miami and
eventually New York there is as yet no
word whether the artist himself might be
as free to travel
you